so
hey everybody look who it is man it's me
kevin smith
we are here at movies uh doing a little
movies action
uh live here at the movies pop-up in
west hollywood
right on santa monica boulevard uh we've
been open for a couple weeks having a
good time we're open for another few
weeks and stuff
uh but we have a very exciting
announcement
uh to bring to you a lot of folks uh
have been like how do you know when are
you bringing movies here
when you bring in movies there uh
bringing movies to jersey drop by
chicago
um we're in iowa i think three people i
know will go
all of these are stellar ideas but
require a lot more capital and time and
travel freedom than we have in this
country right at this moment
so derek who created the movies pop-up
had a brilliant idea and he teamed up
with the good folks
at gold belly to be able to
provide movie meals
everywhere man so that means like if
you're in new jersey and you want to
order
a movie's meal they will send it to you
frozen and then you prepare it when it
gets home
derek come on back here and let folks
know
about this fantastic opportunity for
weeks people have been going how do i
get some movies outside of los angeles
now's the chance this is derek derek has
been doing the pop-up for a while
he did save by the max which was the max
cafe
from uh saved by the bell he did uh
good burger he did uh
peach pit he did break it bad pollo
sarmanos and whatnot
now he's been doing uh movies tell them
about
the gold belly thing man what what
exactly
can they expect if they order it how do
they order it give them the info
step on up here should i hold on this
bad boy okay why not
so a lot of fomo going on a lot of
people saying
i couldn't get a movie's meal i live
10 miles from here and we're like if
they can't get 10 miles from here what
if you live
10 hours from here so thinking thinking
thinking
how do we bring this to the masses right
we want to do a million of these pop-ups
but
it's a hard [ __ ] time to open a new
business in in any city
right so as we're doing it here it's
successful we figured out the right
model for it we figured out the right
ingredient
these fellas gave us the the thumbs up
on the food so we said all right
let's send it out so we contacted gold
belly um
and said hey do you you know what are
your your menu what is your meal kit how
do you do it
very cool way they do it they loved our
business model they loved you guys which
was awesome hey
and we we worked together me and the
team back here amazing collaborative
effort in the back of house crew front
house crew
came up with this movie's meal where it
comes to your door
you order it um twice a week we ship it
out
and there you have it a movie's meal
anywhere in the united states
hawaii alaska puerto rico all those
places we're we're all over the place so
it's
we're broke yeah we're impressed it's
gonna take two extra days to get to
those places but
anywhere outside of a po box you will
get a movie's meal
fully branded cups with
it so the part of a movie's people we
wanted to go i love gold belly right
and we said how do we work with gold
belly and take it to make a movie's meal
so
we said wait before we go further yep
the idea you can't hear us
we got to be louder talk into the mic
yeah totally
uh the idea before here to give him his
mic
um the idea behind a gold belly um
is like you order food and then they
freeze it and send it to you and then
you prepare the meal
yourself popular places across the
united states that people have always
wanted to visit and have no means of
getting to
omaha it's ingenious so all the food is
made
here flash frozen and then
sent to gold belly and then they
distribute it no
you're getting it literally straight
from movies pop-up right here there's no
facility it's done with love
straight from the people you've gave the
thumbs up to right so we're here
we're making it we ship it out fresh
twice a week it's frozen so it stays
fresh
it comes with ingredients that you'll
see when we unbox that
you have the exact instructions from
chef royce
and andre on how to put it together
they're back there somewhere
behind us yeah probably packing up meals
right now so um you get it you do it and
the elevated part we like is we sent out
the cups
we sent out the branded pretzel bags and
the purple napkin and all the [ __ ] you
get when you come here
past that meal making an experience so
you know you're at home
you're literally can feed four to six
with this thing
i'm in idaho i can get a movies you can
get a movies
i'm in uh poughkeepsie i'm getting some
movies
you're getting movies what uh is in the
is it one package is it one this is the
meal this
it all goes the same thing goes out
what's in that meal so
the movie meal is made regular or vegan
completely so you choose from a six pack
so you don't just get one
cow tipper and you're like that's one
and done that was [ __ ] great i can't
wait to do it again
you've got five more to play with or six
burgers big burgers so
you can scarf them or everybody gets to
get them that's sweet
and they go down easy so i'm thinking
you know just like jason muse himself
correct
what what uh besides the six burger the
cow tippers what's in it chocolate
covered pretzels
and they are exquisite yes um
call back okay the uh cup branded cup
four cups come per kit so whatever you
want to drink your beer your wine
everything your soda at home is that one
of the boxes we got the first one done
bring it on over that's andre right
there another big part of this team back
here
andre oh yeah is derek's secret weapon
here man go ahead
let me let me tell you let me let me uh
oh that's dope so it comes in a box with
a
with a big stamp on it says movies 2020
and it's addressed to the recipient and
out it goes that's everything in the box
yep just one box that's going to include
a freezer bag and inside the freezer bag
you're gonna have your complete
meal as well as all the gifts that we're
sending out like
derek mentioned cups deli papers little
napkins
a little present to you and uh all the
toppings we would must put on your
burger like cheeses and pickles but then
you also can put in lettuce tomatoes
whatever
yeah pleases your heart so i just feel
like i have a good job andre
so i don't mean to interrupt so i had to
share that
i could i know what they're doing in
here i haven't seen it but
my the wife at our house gets something
similar
sent to us and it's perfect so my point
is i know this is going to be good
because
the food we get it comes with all those
toppings so she just throws it on the
grill or it heats it up and then throws
the toppings and toppings and this and
that and that
and it tastes amazing so because at
first i was like this is coming in a bag
i don't want to eat it and then all of a
sudden she cooked it up
oh yeah have you ever felt like does
this come in a bag i don't want to eat
it
here's your opportunity to do that thing
eat
[ __ ] from a bag it's from a box comes
right from here freshly made
shipped to you anywhere in the world how
derek how do they do
don't you leave us do they go to
moviespopup.com here tell them
you can go to moviespopup.com or you can
go straight to goldbelly.com
movies so it's live right now
go on in order it just started this is
the first box that's publicly
out we got the first box baby so
well not us but somebody's getting the
first one someone's getting the first
box
so log on we're gonna take orders right
now
and then on the 27th our first order
goes out and from then on
every monday and wednesday we ship out
the orders so if you like it the first
time do it again it's not going anywhere
we're gonna hope that movies is here for
a while
yes excellent job captain so anyone
there watching right now
live uh remember it's open now
order now get it while it's hot because
you don't want to be the last in line
my friends you want to be the first
let's um
last night during uh the airing of
celebrity show off the show that i'm on
on tbs with
sun and lockdown uh we were doing a
giveaway
uh like where we said if you hashtag one
i would pick three people we're gonna
send them
like a party a hater tots party we've
got them here man
it is at heaty beat
was a winner at sherry perron
is a winner and bradley j swenson
they're all winners man they're gonna
get that
uh uh winner movies dinner
uh if you haven't already uh go to
youtube
at some point and watch the new sun and
lockdown short
because it's the judging ends tonight
and then all the hits after that now
don't count so go click on it like today
um but in the meantime look at this man
that's ingenious
um let's get it out of our way slide it
that way
it is a gorgeous wednesday here in los
angeles ladies and gentlemen they just
re-shut the city down a couple days ago
so we had a little bit of freedom but
now everything's back closed down we're
open of course for business because
uh movies is essential you always knew
that but now
it's certified by the government man you
want to order some movies right now
go to moviespopup.com um we got
some amazing giveaways uh to offer you
ladies and gentlemen not the least of
which
um let me see how do we do this well
let's just show first i need
info um where's julian
we need all the info on the things
before i show the things i have
like zero info on it
he stepped out these things that we're
gonna talk about no info
so i need the info otherwise i can't
really
talk about it at all we got some [ __ ] to
show you but we can't show it to you
because i
have no idea who to credit for it and
stuff like that and i don't want to
insult anybody or leave anybody off so
while we get that information
once again man that big news if you're
just tuning in if you're on jay's stream
and you're always throwing bits and the
hype train is moving
now's your chance to go to
moviespopup.com
order movies to be delivered to you
anywhere in the united states man
anywhere any anywhere
yes baby um all right we're finding out
some info in the meantime
josh dip down and show them what we're
talking about down below
look at those sweet chairs ladies and
gentlemen
these sweet adirondack chairs a movie's
design
jay and silent bob design a kevin smith
jersey design bob hawks how gorgeous are
those
liv come on back here and tell us what
those are since
jay's gonna go sit in them look at them
using them damn chairs
in action who provided those chairs liv
who's got
my custom sports chairs my custom
sports chairs thank god you had that
info i never would have remembered that
although it's pretty easy
mycustomsportshares.com
is that where they go to i'm going to
find out that url uh my custom sports
chairs made these awesome
chairs for us man julian put them
together we brought them down here
and we're gonna give them away we're
gonna give away one
and the but the others can be bought
mycustomsportschairs.com
discount code is snoogins oh there you
go so if you ever wanted to own
a deck chair with my face on it or his
face on it or movies face on it
adirondack style look at them damn
chairs tilt down to them chairs josh
show them those damn chairs
so again that's my custom
sportschairs.com discount code is
snoogins for two of them
and we're gonna give away one and how
are we giving away one of them we're
gonna choose a handle from
twitch i don't know if that's the right
move what we should do is somebody
should buy
a movie's package because really it
should be somebody in the area right
who's like cause those chairs are pretty
[ __ ] heavy they'll ship them to you
when you buy them from what is it called
again
mycustomsportschair.com is live
everybody hello
uh standing in for jay as she does
often in life uh half the jane samba
reboot roadshow tour
it was me and her on stage you didn't
notice because bob kurtzman did the
makeup and she was just like snooze to
the new
speak australian to these fools um
i drew me to sing the australian
national anthem like what did you
give them a no tell them tell them what
they chant at games when you were a kid
they're very offensive cheer that sounds
so adorable coming out of you
it's not at games it's at bars by drunk
drunk men and women at bars they go at
least in south australia they go get
ready
just heads up if you've got some kids
watching here
comes some some dirty words ready
go tits out for the boys tips out for
the boys
tits out for the boys tips out for the
boys and what else
dicks out for the girls dicks out for
the girls
dicks out for the girls sticks up for
the girls that's how they roll
it every night on tour that's how they
rolled in australia that comes straight
up from australia
all right the chairs one more time where
can they get these amazing shirts
mycustomsportschair.com jay's sitting in
it right now which one you sitting in
son
how comfortable is that movie's chair
is gonna fit right at home here the
discount code
is snoogins ladies and gentlemen
snoogins
um yep derek come on backwork you can
sit in the chair with jay
you could sit in the chair with jay so
we're gonna give away one of the chairs
yes social distance
we're gonna which we are not we we're
gonna give away one of the chairs but it
should be to somebody who's coming to
get
food so what is a good like what can
they
order like in order to win the chair
go ahead here have the mic you'll take
the mic
liv's going to go back and do her job
thank you liv ideas
we could for your guys approval we
created
i think i sent you guys this mall stand
cookie ice cream sandwich
and we created the chocolate covered
pretzel root beer float for national ice
cream day this sunday
so if people order that it's it's own
experience it's only nine bucks
right you pick one or the other vegan
non-vegan we'll do
a raffle with anyone who gets that and
chews oh
i think you're both lunatics i would say
it's whoever spends the most
on a specific day buy a [ __ ] ice
cream sundae i put you in charge and a
businessman
buy a nine dollar ice cream sundae which
day pick which sunday
this time on sunday sunday and we'll put
it up on the twitter feed and instagram
on sunday whoever orders the most amount
of movies and does that count how does
that count for
the mail away movies like for people oh
because in store i think in-store only
in-store yeah all right so it's for
anyone who orders
uh movies uh the most amount of movies
for
on sunday uh we'll tell you
if you want and you get to walk away
with one of these
sweet adirondack chairs not just the
food which you're going to enjoy
but these one of these sweet adirondack
chairs
yes kind sir do you have something to
ask take the microphone and ask what's
going to say
what time does the store open and what
time does it close because we should
give a cut
because what if someone's here at 10 00
a.m and they spend a thousand dollars
but then at like
noon someone spends a thousand and five
dollars this is an important question
once again there's always somebody to
figure out the rules otherwise you get
some [ __ ] like
quiz show or something like that where
it's payola and
and illegal good that's a good thing
what time does it open
these are the rules the rules we're
going to come up with right now and
you're going to have to hold derek to
every one of them
so they're scrolling right here in the
screen
it starts at 12 p.m ending at 7 p.m
we will tally at 7 01 pm and contact the
winner and also
post their name with their winnings that
they've chose
and when you come here to pick up your
chair and your food you'll take a
picture in the chair
and we'll post it on the very popular
movies pop-up instagram page
yes locally famous we ho
famous and that's as famous as it gets
and
if if doable for when you come to pick
it up
if he calls me ahead of time uh i will
come down
and give it to you i will come here get
it and i will be the one giving it to
you
i couldn't hear that but what i'm
assuming is he said he'll be here when
you pick it up is that what you're
saying i'm saying
as long as as long as uh like again if
i'm like giving the kids
you just come over this way there you go
as long as i'm not like giving the kid a
bath and then i get a call saying come
down they're here
but if you give me some notice and i can
get down here it's not far
i will be the one to give it to you
you're not the first person he's ever
heard that to many people have heard
that very threateningly
his wife every night in the bedroom you
come down here i'm going to give it to
you
um he's going to give it to you ladies
and gentlemen he's a man of his word
you're going to walk away
with not just the fine exquisite movies
cuisine whipped up by
chef royce and his crew you're also
going to walk away with a goddamn
deck chair you're going to be like your
parents and have a deck chair for the
first time in your life
and when people like where'd you buy
that you're like i didn't i won it
because i'm a winner
i still think about everything i ever
won as a child man so i guarantee you
win this chair
you'll think about it on your deathbed
you'll be like remember that one time
when i won the adirondack chair
greatest day of my life and you'll pass
like like charles foster kane
how's that chair down there feel jack
it's actually really good i just wonder
do they make
foot rest like if they made a foot rest
like to add to it that would be amazing
the name of the company is my
sports chair what is it my
custom sport chair
sports chair with an s at the end plural
there's more than one sport
mycustomsportschair.com you go there now
if you want one of these chairs
they don't sell [ __ ] ottomans or
footstools they might
idea man why don't you go create a new
[ __ ] store that
my custom sports footstools [ __ ] why
can't i don't
tell these people like you know what's
missing nothing's missing look at those
amazing i'm not saying it's missing but
i'm gonna try to work with them and see
if i can get my own foot rest made
and jay and so i'm gonna have [ __ ]
dirty space right on top of it so when i
do this
i could put my heels on it if i feel
real naughty i could drop my ball
bag on the [ __ ] kevin's face right on
the ottoman
see america you see how hollywood's like
it's fine but it's missing
something get me that extra thing this
kid used to be from new jersey man and
he would make do
with what he had he would play with the
toys of others
we gave him triple hand-me-down comic
books we gave him an entire run of
vigilante dc comics
more as a joke and he cherished him and
now he would be like i need a footstool
for that vigilante run with his face
um this chair is sweet i've sat in this
damn chair i can't sit in it now because
way the [ __ ] up there
but both of these cats have sat in them
and it can attest to the fact that
mycustomsportschair.com
makes a fine [ __ ] product man and
look at that [ __ ] stickered the [ __ ] out
i like this i like how this one has the
little j it has the real
j and bob like a picture of jay and bob
against his shutters to quick stop
and then it has like the uh the uh
animated version
on the the armrest very
stylish tell you what man we got i know
you're antsy about
like germs and stuff so why don't you
join me back here we leave a mic
there and there's some cats who are
outside who are customers of the movies
pop-up
we can have them come in and say hi and
[ __ ] like that let's do that but we'll
keep socially distant
uh meantime
everyone behind camera is like what the
[ __ ] uh but i'll put on some just grab
whoever wants to come and play
mycustomsportschair.comshares.com
plural coming through with the damn
footstool that jason
muse wanted oh so badly um so damn smart
man
i tell you it's tough to be in a
restaurant and not eat so
chef royce can i get some tater hater
tots
hater tots coming up ladies and
gentlemen
have a seat in the chair real socially
distance and have a conversation kids
keeping your masks on kids uh uh
give him the microphone so we can talk
to him yeah
there you go what should you're gonna
have to talk loud so we can hear it
what's your name my friend
my name is mike mike welcome to the
stream this is mike
what's your name my friend what is it
april so mike and april have come to the
movies pop-up
uh they didn't know that we were gonna
be streaming here today
but in true uh kevin smith fashion if
you show up you're on the [ __ ] show
kids where did you come from to go to
the movies pop-up today tell the
audience
el monte california
so where i can't hear him so somebody's
gonna have to communicate it back to me
because i'm in the
california beautiful he'll josh is gonna
scream the answers back at me it's gonna
go that way and then come back
kids where did you first hear about the
movies pop-up
facebook on facebook
i have some haircut have you eaten yet
yes what did you guys
have i had the chicken
you had a cotton smoker yeah was it
tasty
oh it's very tasty april what do you
have
vegan cow dipper turn out good
chef royce does an amazing job here um
when uh you saw it on facebook how long
ago did you see it kids recently today
before it all happened the postmates and
all that stuff
before this whole coming into the shop
and everything
and april what has been your favorite
part of the experience today
just being able to follow you guys and
seeing it come to life
the food vegan food the merchandise
everything everything
you guys are incredibly sweet we love
you guys
oh i love you guys as well is there
anything while we got a bunch of captive
people
anything you want to plug and stuff like
that anything you want to sell
i want to sell the food the food is
amazing and
yeah the merchandise
just the experience itself is is awesome
it's awesome it's everything and more
that's beautiful man give it up for the
kids kids thank you for coming
thanks for talking to us thank you damn
adorable meet you thanks for eating the
movie we appreciate you guys
we'll cycle you guys out and we'll grab
some other people
oh my god thank you aquaman
thank you afterwards we'll take pictures
stick around
um we should give away the four
explain that liv's gonna come back here
and explain what that means apparently
we're giving away meal kits
i bet you derek will explain it go ahead
first off these chairs are awesome
seriously guys like really these are
awesome i love the haters
we love the hater tots so just making a
post right now on movies kind of
explaining what we're doing
once again um movies is now
shipping nationwide on gold belly what
that means is you can get a movie's meal
to your door
anywhere in the united states any city
any state
puerto rico alaska and hawaii included
so we are going to give away some movies
meal kits right
now how sweet is that man thank you
kevin that's amazing derek's
uh and the good folks here at movies
pop-up are gonna give away
four movie meal kits how do they how do
we do it how are we picking them so
here's
what we're thinking go ahead we just
made a post announcing
that we're live on gold belly or uh on
our instagram
so the way we're gonna do this is people
can log on to our instagram
comment hashtag goldbelly on the last
post we just made announcing gold belly
and uh we will at six o'clock p.m today
central uh pacific time we'll pick the
winners four winners
four winners four movie kits anywhere in
the united states
you don't even have to pay anything left
to finger man go to that page
on instagram on the movies pop-up page
go to the recent post
hashtag gold belly you're in the running
you could win some of the
amazing movies at movies pop-up on
instagram
so movies meal cow tipper vegan or non
vegan
chocolate covered pretzels and then a
whole bunch of collector's items
to round it off the cups a little magnet
to put on your frigerator when you're
done
what has been your favorite part of the
experience thus far derek you've been in
the trenches with the movies
for a minute now um
yeah saying cocksmoker 25 times a day
that is fun
um tell me tell them the story you told
me about the ladies that came out yeah
so we had some watkins walk up here
a couple weeks ago who had no idea what
the restaurant was and that's okay
in living in west hollywood actually i
think they were tourists and they walked
by
and said can we order off the menu and
we're like absolutely what do you have
chicken sandwiches burgers
so they get up to the actual register
walk up
and a lady who's probably just about 70
years old is like
i'll have a [ __ ] smoker please and i'm
like
took everything in me not to let it go
and i was like okay
and the lady was to her friend do you
want a [ __ ] smoker too
like where else could we do this so i
love that and i just you know it's been
really fun
you guys are amazing partners and so
hands-on and cool
with the fans it's been cool to work
with you guys and just
like honestly pump out a menu and bring
it to life you know like
i love the food i love creating this
national ice cream day thing we did with
you guys on sunday and getting creative
so if this sunday it's running it's this
sunday tickets are on sale for it it's
all
it's limited the amount we're going to
do because they're a little bit harder
to produce we've shown both items
they're on our instagram so there's an
ice cream sandwich yep it comes vegan or
regular
ooh and then there's uh a chocolate
chocolate covered pretzel root beer
float vegan or non-vegan or non-vegan
come on man that's tremendous so
if you whoever orders the most movies on
sunday
dollar amount gets to walk away with one
of these fine adirondack chairs but
right now if you go to the movies pop-up
instagram page
go to the latest post announcing gold
belly you respond put gold belly as a
hashtag
you might be one of four people gonna
have a movies a meal kit sent right to
your house
so that you could enjoy a little piece
of jersey straight from
california wherever you live it's a long
distance going back and forth
i did an interview for uh the la weekly
about the pop-up
and um they were like uh you know dogma
is a
like a well-loved movie but like you
know did you really think that
it could that people would remember it
from that movie and i was like
they don't i said they don't really
remember from dogma they remember it
more from
jay and silent bob's strike back and
clerks ii uh
that's where we spent like the entire
movie inside of the movies and stuff
like that
um and then we did it again in jane's
solo bob reboot
but you were telling me that like jay
and [ __ ] strike back is where most
people seem to
know it from like they didn't
necessarily know it from dogma dogma is
like a 21 year old movie you got the
different age brackets right you got a
little bit older of a fan who's thinking
dogma
and then you got the younger newer fan
who who's thinking reboot right
and things like that so but it's a
hybrid and i think
for me personally it's like i said when
people walk by on the street and they
say what is this and we say movies and
they're like uh
we say dogma clerks too and then
jay and silent bob they're like got it
i'm coming in so
so i just thought of that and i have an
idea is there any way that you can get a
little thing over top of the door when
people come in it goes moo
absolutely yes we can i love that every
time we do
something over here you like stop in
midway you're like hang on
i got something and he's like you know
you guys are missing [ __ ] footstools
that's a good idea though we can do it i
love that yeah i love that we got two
weeks left
of the pop-up to pull it off so and
that's another thing our last day is
july 30th
important july 30th is the last physical
day to visit
this pop-up location will there be more
we hope right
but for right now we're in a pandemic
and it's really hard to
plan for the future stuff so till july
30th you can come visit this
and past that uh gold belly we're also
on post mates locally in los angeles
so there's a ton of different ways to
get it man you know we're trying to stay
with the times it's we're living in
covid
we can't do our normal pop-up and seat
200 people here at night and blow it out
and have
speaking stuff with you guys so we get
creative like we sent out signed stuff
on postmates and pushed cards
for delivery and things like that like
we are moving a lot of merchandise yeah
so do people
always buy it in conjunction with food
we just opened up the availability if
someone sends us a dm on instagram
it's a little task worthy but we set up
private like shopping reservations
they typically come and say like i want
you know a signed poster and then while
i'm here i'll get some tots so
we don't want people to feel like they
have to keep paying that total ticket
price to come back they've got that
experience like let's have them back you
know the last two weeks is about
people who maybe couldn't afford it when
we had it ticketed to just like show up
get that shirt get their onion rings and
hang out and the patio helps you know
we've added a couple more tables
there was a bunch of people like outside
which is yeah nice so we have patio
seating
here which is amazing you can take the
food to go you can eat it on our patio
or our postmates will bring it to you if
you're within the radius what's the last
day again sorry
yeah july 30th is our last day i would
love to come one of those days we
coordinate with jordan maybe come
um and again it's hard to like because
of the social
distancing uh sign and do stuff but
maybe i could stand behind the railing
and
and uh take some photos and say what's
up to peeps before you know
the fans would love that we would all
love that so wait so july 31st is the
last day july 30th
july 30th so what we'll do is we'll make
sure the last week
we're down here every day and we're
going to do all kinds of stuff guys
we're going to do merch blowouts we'll
do
continues after this and one of the
things i'm thinking is like how amazing
so that's like this place will go away
but we'll live yes online full mo no
more
um that was that was good no more no
more
and um additionally i think that you
know
who knows we could wind up in other
cities right but for right now like i
said we're winding it down
we're gonna do all kinds of stuff to
make it special at the end we've got
merch i can't talk about yet that we're
gonna debut
right before i think we all know it's
great [ __ ] yeah you've got the movies
um satin jackets that jen wore in the
movie dropping
in the store thursday coming in [ __ ]
tomorrow oh that's dope yeah so we're
gonna have a lot of stuff to make the
ending of this thing really special
um it has been uh super special for me i
know we still got more time and stuff
but it's just been
lovely i miss it when it's gone in terms
of like being able to just drive down
the street and be like oh there's a
place where i can get free tots
and it looks awfully like my imagination
um
what about uh you son what is uh
i'll hold the mics i know you're yeah
what is the uh
i'm sorry what is your thoughts about
the whole movie's experience
can you see yourself being a restaurant
tour
uh i mean i like it i can't imagine like
trying to run something like this but i
i love the whole idea i always i love
the idea when we got the
uh i don't want to touch that but that's
okay i know but i'm still
um sorry better safe than sir um i love
the idea because as soon as i come in
here it's like i really want to start
running around and like
i'm like oh man it'd be great if this
day we could come in and we could take
photos here and do this
i'm just saying like for me i love the
idea because it's great
already but then it's like i i almost
want to
like add more to it and i don't need to
but i'm just saying it's that's
it's i love being like when the store
opened up in westwood when we had the
store opened up in jersey
comics i was already a fan of but didn't
add all the posters and all this stuff
i love coming in and seeing all this
merch and stuff i wanted to grab a
movies uh
face mask and they all are gone which is
a good thing
that means they're selling like cupcakes
so that's cool
what's that about yeah it's great
that's the box yeah we did the yeah we
showed him well yeah he wanted you want
to open it
that's smart go and do it on the chairs
probably makes sense you want me to do
that
i could do what i'm saying but it's
probably easier rather than put up here
where josh can't shoot in we could shoot
it
down i'm sorry i'm i'm closet directing
not even closet i'm just flat out
backseat directing
this is like a version of sorry chef
voice
sorry i'm gonna get in the way i've had
haters i've had twitter shots my whole
life
these are the absolute best
how much salt you put on these
[ __ ] that's what makes it i
swear
i think about it when i'm gone when i'm
not eating i'm sitting at home
my mouth water is going like all them
salty tots that's what i will miss the
most
i love this is a version of what's in
the box a little taste of what's in the
box
movie style knife
welcome to what's in the box i'm moo
he's bee and what we do is we take a
knife and we stab a box
and we open it but today we're opening
the box
from mooby's pop-up if you order a
movie's meal a movie's meal kit
this is exactly what you're gonna get
we're gonna show you what it looks like
inside all right
it's got a bunch of foil
ooh directions and they're nicely
printed movies
movies that tells you how to do it come
on in a little bit so they can at least
see it
that tells you how to cook it all do you
want to read this and then i'll do the
unbagging
this is the movie's instruction it tells
you how to put together the cow tipper
um step by step it's absolutely idiot
proof
all right when you receive your order
you should immediately refrigerate all
meat cheese sauce and pretzels
safe as well all right so there's an
idiot proof direction sheet
boom look at that sweet container
so these are all chocolate covered
pretzels
so you got yourself a plastic container
it's got four bags of chocolate covered
pretzels each one
has the movies logos on the wrapper and
the
package itself has a boobies los angeles
20 20. stick it right on top
there are your chocolate covered
pretzels then what i love how licensed
wrapped look inside
the preparation necessary here and even
then boom
whoa i'm rapping
let's bring inside this bag oh oh
oh chisel this one's not going out
we got four cups uno
dough and then we got a little
little uh
branded deli paper so you can wrap your
burger
we got the magnet uh collector's magnet
oh it's a pit oh magnet yeah
um so like i said we got the cups here
they're wrapped in their own bag to
avoid any condensation so they hold up
when you get there
you got your pretzel bag fully branded
pretzel bags
oh my god dude you get like the full oh
[ __ ] son
why who is that oh i got a penny on my
chest
oh oh wait no that's me i'm a chest
magnet
[Music]
all right there you go so i love that
it's a bag with a bag with a bag and a
bag
what else purple and then you got oh
[ __ ] you ain't got
none unless you got buns hun
you ain't got none unless you got buns
huh
no i'm just kidding six hamburger buns
uh
chef royce you wanna come talk about
this stuff look at that
dude he put it all together for us jump
on over by the chair take this bad boy
pickles mustard cheese
uh and mayonnaise if you want you could
sit there yeah
so there you go
so we got super super special potato
buns
that we use here at the movies pop-up
oh they're so great um super special
potato buns we use here at the movies
pop-up we've got the same cheese we're
using
the pickles which are the key to the
whole damn thing
got a little bit of mustard just gonna
make a little smiley face of mustard on
the bottom of your bun
gonna put the pickles on there you're
gonna use some red onions that you get
at home oh
special secret movie sauce that i love i
love that it comes like in a container
like this
the bummer is getting uh a burger uh to
go or something they give you you're
like can i get some
special sauce and give you one little
packet yup and you're like
trying to squirt it on licking this side
they don't look at that you ain't got to
squirt
[ __ ] now
and then you got whoa boom and there's
the burgers
i would recommend cooking them before
you do that yeah yeah
no but it is it stay it's like freezing
these are the burger burgers and then we
will also have the beyond
vegan burgers available and then of
course same ones same
boys are in there and
yes this is the straight up meal the non
the vegan meal
will also have our house-made cashew
cream instead of the cheese
to go on top of the burgers and pretty
much everything else
besides the the pretzels will have a
vegan dark chocolate pretzel
everything else will be exactly the same
the our house movie special sauce is
vegan
because kevin is and that's important to
us
dude
the chef some questions what now in
terms
this is what the beyond version looks
like oh i get to take this home
look at that man it's a stack of beyond
movies right there
yeah um can't smell it because it's
sealed
what what now in terms of uh
being a chef
nobody when they're learning their
cuisine goes i want to make food that
ships all around the world
so was it a challenge to go like
i got to come up with a meal that i know
will make it
many states away it i mean it is kind of
a unique challenge i think what gold
belly does is super
super rad but i think it's it's you have
to just kind of rethink
a little bit of the process and make
sure that everything can
that you can package everything to
actually travel super well
and then you know retool thankfully we
had been thinking about this
from pretty early on right so we didn't
really have to change anything from what
you're getting
in the restaurant here so you're gonna
get the same experience that you would
get at the movies pop-up in los angeles
in anywhere you are and also made by the
same
people exactly we're not even like well
this is it's
coming from a location in ohio that's
approximating it you know like
everything that would be made here is
getting shipped the same beautiful
gloved hands
that make it here made with love the
same gloves
hey the same hands that made the food i
just ate yeah making this food that
winds up in your hands
popup.com uh is the address to go to
uh and show them the tags on the box
like it's got branding all over it man
you can keep that box forever it's got
little stamps all over it and [ __ ]
packaged very well the boy is saying
chef voice thank you so much not just
for showing us this
but for putting together all the food at
the movies pop-up
everyone has loved it all i've ever
heard about the food i think most people
were assuming like
they'd come for the ambiance and the
food would be whatever but like
what you always hear from everybody is
like the food's legit good
well good we're not trying to [ __ ]
around that's true man this is a real
restaurant man
fictional one but a real restaurant in
real life real food
that is very true real food fictional
restaurant that would be our tagline
if we ever went national and we are
national right now you want movies you
want it at home
you want a movie's meal kit go to
moviespopup.com click on the
gold belly entry there you want to try
to win one of these bad boys they're
giving away four
the movies pop up man go to their
instagram page the movies pop-up
instagram page
go to their picture the the one that
announces the most recent post announces
the gold belly thing
uh comments on it with the hashtag
goldbelly you could be picked to win uh
one of four movie meal kits that we're
sending out
into the world man and sunday ladies and
gentlemen in case you're just tuning in
sunday is national ice cream day and to
celebrate that the movies pop-up is put
together
um uh ice cream sandwich uh vegan and
non-vegan
and a root beer float uh vegan and
non-vegan man
uh so that's national ice cream day but
on sunday here at movies pop-up
whoever orders the most in a single
order man like the most like you know
100 200 whatever most amount of money
spent by
one patron on sunday is gonna also
they're gonna walk away with their food
that they paid for
because that's the law here in weho but
they're also going to walk away
with one of these sweet adirondack
chairs man
josh probably showing you them right now
look at them chairs
what do you do with a chair like that j
look at this one muse this is like my
favorite but i mean of course
look at that chair in action he's
sitting in that chair
if you ever wanted to be j muse sitting
in a chair here's your chance you order
enough
food for movies pop up on sunday you're
gonna walk away with one of these chairs
throw it in the back of your car
throw it on top of your car drive around
beverly hillbilly style in beverly hills
is a local a win type situation um
let's see what else uh can i tell you
celebrity showdown ladies and gentlemen
i'm still in
go watch my latest episode after all
this it's on uh the tbs youtube channel
episode uh five i believe of sun and
lockdown
we had some winners last night because
we gave away some hater top party
packs and the the gold belly giveaway
winners were
uh hidey bee uh cherie perron
and bradley j swenson man winners all
ladies and gentlemen uh what
uh what are you what do you got
they do they shift back as well
move so you can recline a little bit
he's like comfort leisure that is my
middle name
what are you planning to do on your
stream all day long sir
do you want to take my clean mic here
hold on
yeah but i will do i'll do this
and then i'll touch it and then i'll
give it to you um
all right guys uh so wait because we're
pretty much 20 20 ladies and gentlemen
where you can't touch anything without
[ __ ] putting on some
we can't jerk each other off anymore
without putting lots of [ __ ] lather
on our hands
and if it gets in the tip ow that's all
i'm saying
dude you got to see like now i have to
swallow because when i try to spit it
back
like i forget and i put the mask over my
face and then i'm like
oh and i get it right in my and when he
talks about spitting he ain't talking
about this fine movies food nobody spits
out boobies man
in the movies that may taste like piss
and flies but in real life yes
yummy i just ate me a thing of tater
tots yeah
i could sit here and just they're like
they're like snacks more than
anything i could see it's like a meal
for me man i just i plowed through them
like a pig um
let me ask you this what are you gonna
do on the stream for the rest of the day
all right so uh i'm gonna go back home
and then uh you know we'll talk a little
bit i
chat probably chat and i might throw in
a game or two so you guys
see because uh i i don't know if we're
gonna
so the giveaway is the four giveaways
we're not doing we're not doing for
they do on sunday no they do when are
you guys doing sundays
for the uh for the instagram thing
six o'clock tonight on instagram they'll
announce the winners of the four
uh movie meal kits and then sunday
they'll be doing the
chair giveaway to whoever buys the most
movies that day
um but right now if you're like contests
i've got my own money i'm not leaving
this to chance
i'm gonna buy this [ __ ] right now you
could buy one of those sweet adirondack
chairs
at my custom sports championship yeah
there's a little place
in the front of the car on the front of
the chair liv my custom sports chair
mycustomsportschair.com if you want to
buy one of those or
if you want to buy a movie's meal kit
man have it delivered to you
anywhere in the united states go to
moviespopup.com gold belly got you
covered man
gold belly looking out for you i'm going
to take some stuff from here
uh don't tell them and i'm going to do
we'll play marbles when i get home and
i'll try to give
i'll do a giveaway when i get back
problem is i'm going to shut down the
stream and then start
over again so hopefully you guys will
come back because we're here of course
and if you're watching on my youtube
channel or my facebook channel are we
doing that as well right now
yes so if you're watching disregard
everything he
just said if you're sitting there going
marble game what the [ __ ]
that's a twitch thing obviously um but
they could come watch me on my twitch
after if he like when we're done i don't
know i
uh one of us has a birthday coming up
ladies and gentlemen
that's right it's your birthday and you
know august 2nd i'm going to turn
50 years old and the next big
announcement we'll have for you
is just exactly how we're going to
celebrate
that [ __ ] national uh when i finally
hit the
half century mark man everyone's been
asking me hey
how are we celebrating 50 years of kev
that's a good question
all right my mom asked me so we've we
figured something out man some socially
distant fun
that you can engage with us uh in and
we'll tell you about it probably
next week or something like that it's
it's you know if you're in the la area
it's for you uh otherwise you might have
to travel for it and nobody wants to get
on planes and stuff
uh but a car would be handy anyway you
see what i'm saying
you drive it's a you know yeah oh just
it's a big head yeah um what else can i
tell you
uh that i've been doing um masters of
the universe continues
a pace very well you know what [ __ ] me
telling you what i want to talk about
let's we got people on the stream right
people talking and [ __ ]
live you go are you looking at it give
us some questions man liv
is going to ask us some of your
questions right now
it's going to take less a second because
we're obviously
delayed and stuff um but we've only got
a few minutes uh
left kids so yeah i was just about to
i can rock i can rock something here let
me see if i can get it
here we go great question from andre
there some people said that they're
asking about the physical location where
is this movie's pop-up where are you
right now we'll come save you they're
saying
we are uh right in weho ladies and
gentlemen in the crotch
of weho and this is santa monica
boulevard and la brea is the cross
and what's the cross over here formosa
so
it's right next door to the formosa man
um you'll see it as you're driving down
santa monica boulevard you can't miss it
only cow on the window and stuff says
i'm eating it
um come on in and visit us go to
moviespopup.com to order
uh and then come here and come grab it
take pictures josh show them the
some of the [ __ ] over there look at that
cool ass [ __ ] there's a quick stop man
there's a rst video uh there's a big old
blunt man in chronic
they decked this place out man so when
you come to pick up your food
it's like selfie station uh galore man
he gets to take pictures
all over the joint as well sorry guys
someone asked is the
uh ig giveaway international is the
instagram giveaway for the four meals
international no it's just
goldberg ships us only folks sorry
international folks
yes yeah we'll get one step at a time
sd vince and coke sorry bro that's uh
not yet but hopefully eventually uh oh
got another one yeah there's one right
here
look i got i look like a bandito with
the mask now it's like down here
and stuff hey kevin jay i just started
watching all of kev's movies and release
order jersey girls next
what movie was the most fun for both of
you to work on
um what was the most fun i mean
jane's salamba i honestly both of the
jane zombob movies were hands down the
most fun
strike back was a blast because every
day
somebody new joined us and we were never
bored like
hey it's this person hey it's this
person and he never got sick of them
because they were gone
by the end of the day so reboot
functioned in kind of the same way
uh and so that for that reason was fun
but we didn't have as much time
or as much money to do reboot so we were
always running and gunning like it was
you never had time to like kick back and
be like we're having a good time because
you were
trying to make your day and stuff like
that still it doesn't mean it was like
hell on earth we had a good time doing
it but
it was not as relaxed as jay and silent
bob strike back
we had that [ __ ] late 90s early
aughts money back then man we're like
take your time
you got all the time in the world and
you know when we did reboot though like
you better hurry up you only got two
bucks
so but both of them fun you know always
made fun by the people that you're
working with and
both casts and crews were really
wonderful you know what i always i
always tell everyone for me 100
mall rats is my favorite because it was
my first studio movie
and i was like 20 years old and it was
such a surreal experience
for a 20 year old highlands kid being
out in minnesota staying in a hotel
getting per diem like you get per dam
which was like spending money throughout
the week they don't do that anymore but
yeah per diem is like when you get to a
place and you're already getting paid to
do a job but like you're away from home
and they're like well we got to feed you
during the day so here's
some free money and they would literally
give you cash like a hundred dollars or
something
it's like an envelope yeah there's like
an envelope so you get like 400 a day
depending on
like what whatever but it was like three
to four or 500 bucks
in the 70s they called it coke money
and they had like we had stunt guys and
wardrobe
um it was such a surreal fun i got to
meet jason lee and ethan to plea the
first time
uh i got to meet stan lee for the first
time it will always be my
favorite and most fun but i want to ask
you because i people ask me all the time
and i was saying
jody holdsworth says per diem is bud
money you ain't kidding back then it
wasn't though but it would be today
go ahead what's your question because i
know for you same as me it was your
first studio movie so
do you feel like you had a little less
fun on that than the others hold on
bonanista just gave us some information
i know but this is good information
because we were wrong about it bonanisa
who is also one of your biggest [ __ ]
chit givers and stuff like that so you
better represent
and respond anyway bonanista says per
diem is allowance based on the cost
of things in a specific area the
government
does it all the time so all this all
these years we've been like over
explaining per damn to people going oh
in movies they give you per diem
and i bet you 75 percent of those people
looking at us going like we know of per
diem as [ __ ]
but 25 percent of people are so nice to
not say anything let us keep explaining
it and [ __ ]
anyway back to you thank you yes it knew
so what was your question
my question was for you it had to be
different because it was your first
studio movie but do you feel like
because it was your first and the
pressure was on were you more nervous
about like
oh my god i can't [ __ ] this up i've done
clerks but that was you
yes that was our that was your movie
absolutely
first one i made with my friends so this
next one mall rats we were making with
studio money it was millions of dollars
first one cost 27 000 bucks this cost
five million um and i'd never done it
before i don't know what the [ __ ] i was
doing
so he never worked with a crew beyond my
just my friends
so yeah i was very scared the whole time
and then throw into it
the studio was like we don't want that
guy to play jay they wanted somebody
else so i'm like
balancing that as well true fighting the
good fight i'm glad i did though because
think about it if it wasn't you
probably never would have eventually
made jane silent bob strike back
like if it was seth green that's who the
studio wanted seth green to play jay
like you know i i'm sure i would have
enjoyed working with seth but it
wouldn't have been the same thing we'd
already done jay and samba
but the fact that we got to do it
together in mall rats and then i was
like all right let's keep going
and so we did it we never would have
gotten a strike back if it hadn't been
you
jay and salam bob strike back and even
more so jane some bob reboot
is really only the the kind of movie
that you could ask your friend to do
with you
like you know it's like i couldn't go
out and cast that movie like let me get
jon hamm to play jay
like the movie would never happen and
stuff but like i could go to you and be
like you were jay let's make a movie
about
jay and sam bob and you're like all
right and it totally worked out so
for many reasons i'm glad it was you and
not seth green
although if i was friends with seth
green i'd have some of that [ __ ]
robot chicken money
which spends like crazy he's a [ __ ]
multi-millionaire man did you ever see
seth green's [ __ ] robot chicken
all the money they print off that show
it's like a goddamn atm that
that cartoon network money that adult
swim money
i wish he was jay no i don't yeah this
guy
i wish we were friends yeah [ __ ] god why
didn't i listen to universal
uh let's see what uh other cats are
saying man
they just scared the [ __ ] at me liv's
got something yell it out liv
bl fisher's asking what's up with moose
jaws i did my second draft of moose jaws
um and it's being looked at by the by
the people who
uh are thinking about putting loot into
it right now
so once they you know say hey
uh it's ding dong kovid's dead if that
ever happens
uh then we're back to work but for right
now
it's tough to tough to make moose jaws
in my house
silent lockdown i can make in my house
moose jaws
not so much again anyone tuning in right
now check in son in lockdown on youtube
with kevin smith celebrity show off
go to the youtube tbs channel and click
on
my show right now annie leakes is
beating me man she's gone
nene leakes has an army of people she
called them something i don't know like
a name like
some people have a name for their family
like
yeah like ralph garman has garmin and
like lady gaga calls her audience little
monsters and stuff
i think she's got names for for her
audience as well but yeah her audience
has come out strong but i don't need to
be number one i just need to be in the
top three
yeah just say i'm bored right and
actually we've gone so much further
than i ever imagined we would so if we
got kicked off i'd be like you know
it's not going to happen i mean it could
happen this is a good one for me
yeah the kid would spoke up this morning
she goes um
dad in that movie why are you trying to
get
um potatoes up to daddy did you show her
the shirt kevin yeah yeah yeah
and she goes and what happened to
harley's boyfriend cause like he just he
got hit with all these potatoes
and then he like was laying there and he
said can you it was so
adorable as a storyteller i've captured
the imagination of a five-year-old yes
she's like i need to know more what
happened to the boy after he got hit
with the hater talking
on youtube so she's watching she's
getting those views for you i got three
views from
logan did she watch this week's episode
with all the podcast people
no she didn't know all my podcast pals
do cameos on this week's episode
i'm uh i'm writing uh next week's or the
next one if we make it
uh this weekend or this week we shoot it
this weekend
when do you fight you see you find out
like in the next day or two so
they don't well we just found out that
we made it last night
so now we find out if we make it again
on tuesday on tuesday okay and then you
still okay i see a thing
it's a fingers crossed yeah let's go
come on everybody tune in
um speaking of tuning in it's four
o'clock ladies and gentlemen and you
tuned in for a damn
hour of watching uh me eat tater tots
right in front of you
in conversation like a pig everyone
hates that on podcasts so when people
eat they're like don't eat during the
podcast i used to do that back in the
day
and they were like stop eating on the
podcast there are chips in my ear
that's what they don't like creeps mouth
some people don't like that
um but you like it cause you've been
here man thanks for hanging out with us
uh thanks to derrick and the good folks
at movies pop-up
thanks to gold belly um who is
taking us on the road you want some
movies pop-up you want a movie's meal
kit
go to moviespopup.com and order your
gold belly version of movies
anywhere in the united states oh yeah
and you want to sit down while you're
eating that
then order one of those sweet ass
adirondack chairs kevin smith style
from uh mycustomsportschair.com and
don't forget
sunday whoever orders the most movies
pop-up here at the location
you're going to walk away with that
chair it's the chair of your choice
it's going to be yours and jason muse
might be here to give it to you yes
and i'll maybe i'll tag it for you even
as well so
order big on sunday national ice cream
day ladies and gentlemen
order find a little league team that
just won their game and get them all ice
cream
everyone's like there is no little
league you [ __ ] idiot we're all
inside that's right
little league has been canceled as well
for the 2020 season um but movies pop-up
is still alive and happening go to
moviespopup.com to order
movies food movies merchandise
anything it's a fun place to go go to
the instagram uh page of movies pop up
you might be able to win
one of four free movies meal kits
they're gonna be sending out
uh don't forget to check out the new
episode of sun and lockdown on
youtube tbs youtube channel right now i
need your clicks
um and uh there it is my birthday's
coming coming up next week we'll tell
you
what's going to happen next week on jay
and sam bob gets twitchy we've got boxes
to open up again yes
boxes of toys so next week my house
opening up some cool boxes
i'm also after we're done here we shut
down i'm running home
and hopefully i'll be back up on my
stream uh for my twitchers and whoever
else
uh streaming some more stuff uh we'll
chat a little more
giving us some games and i'm gonna try
to take something good here
to give to you guys oh look at that he's
giving away prizes
uh thanks for hanging out with us if
you're on jay's twitch stream
that was your personal message to him uh
to you if if you're on my youtube
stream uh thanks for watching uh if
you're on my facebook stream
thanks for watching don't forget
moviespopup.com
don't forget sun and lockdown i need
your clicks
uh don't forget jane sambab forever
yeah there it is man for uh jane zombob
get twitchy i'm kev smith jason muse
go get twitchy kids
you